Okay, so there's this tug-of-war between suppression. What's the immune systems? I mean, I need a really healthy immune system to kill cancer. That's right.
So how does the immune system promote cancer? Well, I said that it cancer itself can evade the immune system's response, but there's
cancer is promoted by an immune response in the case of I think I'll just talk about this slide here. I have about 10 other ones.
So I'll just talk about this slide here to end. Cancer is promoted by an immune response in chronic
inflammation. So this ties its back to Lyme disease, or H. Pylori, or Coxaxi virus, or a chronic mercury toxicity, or any other
toxicity. Anything that's going to produce a chronic low-grade inflammatory state presupposes me to cancer.
For a variety of reasons that the rest of my slides talk about, on a very technical note, but just understand that.
Chronic inflammation is our enemy, but you have to balance that. If I have an immune response to kill a
strep that I'm just exposed to, that is an inflammatory response. So inflammation, it goes back to what I initially said, nothing is bad in
itself. It's overabundance of anything, especially overabundance over time. So chronic inflammation is a low-grade infection for a long
period of time. Wait a second. Now we get back to Lyme disease. So I have chronic Lyme disease, TH1 dominant. I'm always firing this immune response.
I always have this low-grade inflammatory. That's why my joints ache. That's why my muscles ache. That's why I got this headache. That's why I can't
think clearly, because I had inflammation in the brain. So I got all these upper-border neuron symptoms as well. There are logical issues, because I have inflammation in my
hand. So you were really setting yourself up for even graver problems, because chronic inflammation promotes cancer. Cancer can promote chronic
inflammation as well, but chronic inflammation can promote cancer. So let's go into, how do you actually treat these things? So there are some
things that you can do from a nutritional approach to address chronic inflammation in itself. First of all, my number one thing is always find out why. So that's my
tagline, I guess. It's tagline that are signed outside our clinic right now. Don't we move? Never stop asking why. You've got to find out why. So I have chronic inflammation,
you know, with giving me symptoms of brain fog, early dementia, I can't think straight. I have episodes where I get eager issues, anxiety, depression, et cetera, et cetera. I have aches and pains, I don't feel good. I have, you know, so I'm a diagnosed with
Lyme. Okay, so number one, find out why. Is it the Lyme that's causing the issues? Is the person autoimmune? Number two. What dominance are they? Number three. What's the best treatment
approach to get rid of this? Do you have to fix the gut? You have to fix the detox pathways. You have to heal the organs. I wish I could stay sit here in a two-hour lecture and tell you exactly how to get somebody better that has chronic
Lyme or has has cancer. I wish it was that easy. It's just not. Everybody's individual and everybody has to be treated as such. But using frequency medicine can be really helpful, but that alone doesn't get rid of
inflammation. That can help frequencies can really help kill the antigen, but you still got to get rid of the inflammation. So what are some of my favorite things to do with getting rid of inflammation? So I already told you one of
them is anti-inflammatory herbs like curcumin. So curcumin is tuberic. It's the active ingredient of tuberic. What did I say you have to take curcumin with? A fat. What else can you add to curcumin that won't increase its effectiveness?
Biopterant. Pepper. Black pepper will help increase. So there's a number of products on the market today that actually have. It's already pre-emulsified in the fat, and it already has pepper in it. So you can just take it that way. So that will help decrease the inflammation.
But again, if I'm just going to decrease the inflammation and I'm not getting rid of the cause of inflammation, that's like having a barn full of rats because you have a manure pile in your barn, and you just get out your 22, and you're just going to sit outside your barn and shoot rats. You're never going to end. You have to get rid of the manure pile that's causing the rats. So you have to find out that reason why. So that makes sense.
So finally with cancer, let's finish up this because only five minutes left here that we've got to go to break, and then that will have a question and answer session, the place of that last session that helps. So dealing with cancer in the immune system, what we find, we test for the reason of the person. So in our clinic, there's four pillars to take care of a cancer patient. So there is number one, you've got to find out why the person's got the cancer.
That's why they have a tumor growing in their body. So the reason why, remember I said, is there's an abnormality that caused a lack of apoptosis in a rapid replication cycle. But we've got to find out what that reason why is. Now that's completely ignored and standard oncology. Here's your cancer. This is the chemo we're going to use. Well, why do I have it? What? So it's just not even thought of.
There's a lot of studies on the reason why people have cancer. They're all post mortem studies. Oh, after you die, then we'll figure out why you have it. It's not flying for me. So person can have cancer because of H. Pylora. Again, we use that example. Wouldn't be wise to get rid of the H. Pylora.
Couldn't H. Pylora cause metastasis? I think we should get rid of the H. Pylora 2. Let's try to get rid of your cancer. Let's get rid of the H. Pylora 2.
Second pillar is, what are we going to use from a nutraceutical standpoint to kill that cancer? So our talk on cancer was quite brief here.
But if you don't deal with the nutraceutical piece of cancer, what are we going to use that is going to be most effective to kill that growing cancer mass, whatever we're going to have victory.
So from a standard oncology approach, they're using chemotherapy. Well, that's all good and fine, but chemotherapy has its side effects besides being sickness.
Side effect is that it promotes more metastasis through reducing the immune system function so that circulated tumor cells could grow.
But sometimes you've got to use chemotherapy too. But there is a nutraceutical approach that will work best for that patient. Thirdly, I think you have to use a knife.
Since I started using a knife 16 years ago, we have never taken on a cancer patient without demanding that they get a knife machine. So that is essential.
And then you've got to program it the right way. So we do a lot of work to figure out the frequencies. And I personally program everybody's program and they use it every single night. And every single night is a different program.
So their Monday through Sunday is a different program that they're using every single night.
And then fourthly, there's a whole mess of other stuff, like we kind of touched on here. How's their liver, how's their kidneys, how's their colon, how's their...
You got to address all those things and it becomes mind-boggling and exhausted sometimes. But you have to do that if you're going to have success.
Okay? But I don't have cancer. How can I prevent it? Biggest way is decrease chronic inflammation in a source of chronic inflammation.